hello everyone welcome to this session
workforce of the future my name is Jason
Hawk I'll be moderating the panel before
I introduce the speaker let me say a few
things
stage right few years ago Mackenzie the
company did a study where they're able
to identify the jobs that are gonna be
obsolete as well as the other kind of
jobs that's going to be high in demand
so it's clear that the jobs that require
reputation manual labor will be gone any
guess was the other kind of jobs are
which will be high in demand what kind
of jobs will behind demand in the future
so that again caregiving okay so more
Sherri's right so it's more about you
know human human skills your ability
will be creative get things done focus
concentrate work well net group will
rapport I'll tell a good story be a good
speaker and the Kuan of the question
that will try to answer that this panel
is is there a room for technology to
help us build some of those human skills
I know it may sound counterintuitive
hopefully by the end of the panel this
will be kind of clear something of it so
we have a very diverse panel today to
talk about this topic
the first speaker will be skip Rizzo who
is a professor at the University of
Southern California skip has done many
years of research looking into AR VR
technology to help individuals with
autism PTSD individuals with brain
trauma and he will tell us more about
what's the latest in terms of technology
give us some demos and videos the second
speaker will be some seeing ball who
from micro cell research along with
colleagues they introduced our idea of
micro productivity in this age of
inattention we're always distracted is
there a role for technology kind of take
it to complex tasks and break into small
pieces and finish them so she will tell
more about that we were lucky to have
Phil Pisa
who runs the Stanford
careers distinguished career Institute
prior to that he was the Dean of
Stanford School of Medicine for 12 years
so you look at the same problem from a
different angle I know that once I had a
conversation with Phil he mentioned that
a kid that's born today there's a 60%
chance he's gonna go live up to 100 so
the notion that I'm gonna have education
then have a career and retire it's no
longer there we may have multiple
careers and how should you prepare for
that kind of transition and finally
we're gonna have John Kleinberg who is a
Titch professor at Cornell University
and you will talk about as we deploy
many of this AI driven technology how do
you ensure that the decision that
systems make are fair and biased so
that's the agenda today and the logistic
is that every speaker will speak for 10
to 12 minutes and hopefully that will
leave us 30 minutes of Q&A I will also
give a demo of a system that gives you
feedback on your speaking skills and
during lunch I was able to get Eric
Horvitz be a participant so I have his
data so I'll show you how many times he
said um how the characteristics of his
smiles I'll give that demo as well so on
that note let's welcome our first
speaker skipper zone thank you okay
I think oh there we go
alrighty well I'm gonna make the case
that the field of mental health
treatment and rehabilitation it's gonna
be fundamentally changed by the
introduction of technologies in ways
that people haven't anticipated and the
skill sets of the people that are going
to graduate school now will start to
change and I hope I'd be I'm a going to
be able to make the case here I'm going
to start off very simply by presenting a
couple of use cases in the areas that we
work and to kind of give you an idea of
the mental health and rehab space that
we've addressed and then present some
use cases showing how
been done previously and how we're going
to be doing it now and in the future and
also the impact that it has on our
patients a lot of the work we'll be
presenting is from our Research
Institute the Institute for Creative
Technologies at the University of
Southern California our lab is the Med
VR lab we've been around for a while
over the years we've addressed
psychological issues cognitive
assessment and rehabilitation physical
therapy occupational therapy and use of
virtual humans and just a quick
run-through
that's a simulation of Iraq or
Afghanistan that we use to deliver
exposure therapy to treat PTSD and
servicemembers coming back from Iraq and
Afghanistan that's what it looked like
ten years ago you can see the
improvements in the graphics but in this
case we took a treatment system and
translated in into a cognitive
assessment system so within that
environment military relevant
environment we assess attention memory
executive function things like that we
don't just do military stuff this is
from way back in 1997 I believe doesn't
always have to be immersive VR you can
interact with stuff in this case mental
rotation training system another
application for children this is what a
child sees in a headset this is from
2003 I believe a test of attention
processes so child has to pay attention
stimuli on the blackboard but meanwhile
there's distractions in the classroom
teacher answers the door kid in the back
just through a paper airplane school bus
can go by the window and so forth in
physical therapy this is something we
use Microsoft Kinect and various other
sensors to track user movement embed it
within a game based environment to try
to make the very boring repetitive and
often frustrating work of physical
therapy after a stroke or brain injury
spinal cord injury a little bit more fun
and engaging so people do more of it and
then our virtual human work in these
areas this is an app from 2012 I believe
works
patient that we developed for the USC
School of Social Work as a training -
one I'll let a little bit of this play
out naturally I'm sorry miss together.we
brings you in today well my wife told me
she thought I should talk to someone see
they're pretty concerned about me since
they've soldier Sudan businesspeople did
you happen to know the soldier yes it
was a friend but have it the right once
or twice you seem normal at the time I
guess I'm afraid and I end up like him
do you have any plaster yourself no it
certainly caught my mind especially
lately I just need it all to stop
sometimes I can't handle it so I like to
say that this gives novice clinicians
and training a chance to screw up a
bunch with a virtual patient before they
get their hands on a live one and if you
know when I went to grad school as a
clinical psychologist my first year
write a couple books on therapy took a
couple classes and maybe role played a
little bit with a fellow grad student
and that I'm seeing patients so I think
we can up the game in clinical training
by the use of this kind of technology
finally this this character was a guy we
put online starting around 2011 and it
was for military service members and
veterans coming back from the war that
didn't want to go see a shrink didn't
know if they had a problem but they
could go online and talk about PTSD get
asked questions character would do some
screening questions back at some point
he may say hey it looks like you're
going through some some hard times if
you punch in your zip code on the right
I'll pop up a list of providers in your
area and I can talk to you a little bit
about treatment so not a replacement for
clinical care but a tow in water I'll
just let him introduce himself with what
the real person if that's what you're
asking
but I'm based on the personality and
experiences of real soldiers and Marines
I'm still just a piece of software but
I'm getting better all the time so
hopefully I can be a helpful piece of
software to talk to okay so with that if
we look back in history clinical VR
really got its traction back in the
early to mid night
these mainly focused on exposure therapy
for people with phobias fear of heights
flying public speaking
since that time last 25 years as the
technologies advance we've seen really
an evolution of the scientific
literature documenting where VR makes a
difference and these are clinical
conditions where either as an assessment
tool treatment tool or tool for
scientific research and VR is pretty
pretty well documented to be a value in
these areas the best metaphor for why we
apply this clinically is aviation
simulation so just as an aircraft
simulator with test and train piloting
ability we can test train teach and
treat wide range of human activities all
using simulation technology and AR when
I talk about some you know talking
generally mixed reality and it's the
ultimate Skinner box particularly with
VR so the use case is you've seen the
beginnings of some of these and some of
the work that I outlined but just real
quick if you look at traditional methods
for cognitive assessment you have a
child your your kid your not sure if it
has a DD or perhaps autism or whatever
you bring them to a neuropsychologist
and you give them a battery of paper and
pencil tests well that those are all
skills it'll probably be maintained but
in the future clinicians and currently
clinicians are using this are going to
be using things like the virtual
classroom I showed from 2003 this is an
updated version that we developed and
tested with a Taiwan population in a
group in Taiwan Taipei but basically a
controlled stimulus environment for
assessing attention under realistic
conditions where we can introduce
distracting stimuli similar to the test
environment the criterion environment
here's some another feature to this this
is a parent talking about the very first
version we did
from 99 mm it does offer one clear
benefit to parents of children with ADHD
empathy it just punctuated to me how
utterly distractible the minds their
minds are just to see the process helps
me understand them even more and maybe
to even more patient with them anything
I could feel what it was like to be in
their shoes I want um another project
job interview training with high
functioning folks on the autism spectrum
built a variety of characters who could
serve the role as a job interviewer for
training we could make we could put them
in different backdrops make them cranky
or make them you know positive or
neutral here's this character in a more
positive state I'm glad you're here in a
minute we'll get into some questions
about the child but before we do why
don't you just tell me about yourself no
we can make her cranky or we could pick
another character and do that this is an
entry-level position I guarantee there
will be things you won't like about this
job that said what's the most important
thing you think you're looking for in a
job it's a good program and it teaches
you how to do an interview and it
teaches you how to be a new situation
was another person and did you see your
performance improve so that's some data
from previous work and now it's been
expanded to use by veterans and
incarcerated juvenile delinquents about
to be released so generally it's going
to change the way the vocational
counselors work with folks so a little
bit different is a little bit of therapy
in here a little anxiety reduction but
it's a skill training tool physical
therapy this is an easy one you can see
traditional methods for physical therapy
now physical therapists in addition to
doing this I'm not saying we're going to
throw everything
but our gonna have to know how to work
with software and how to set things up
in a way where people can do things like
this
you know upper extremity reaching with a
leap motion attached to the front of a
headset so you can see your hands in
real-time but interact with 3d graphics
and here's a little more and I'm just
gonna pop up this person here real quick
[Music]
so we're not just changing a practice
we're changing how our patients might
interact with practice and maybe engage
them in ways that you know be difficult
with traditional methods standardized
patients getting actors to you know be
part of the training as you saw with the
the social work application well we've
gone from that to a system where it's a
configurable system where you can just
like the job interview you can pop the
character into different backdrops and
you can author natural language dialogue
management you can select from a library
of 40 different characters you can
inflate each character to three
different weight classes and generally
you can go from the old way of you know
see one do one teach one in medicine to
you know
continually practicing with various
virtual patients until your scores reach
a certain criterion finally therapy
traditional therapy well you know talk
therapy we all know what that is and
that will always be a part of therapy
but we can now start to do things where
we can put people in simulations that
are relevant to amplify the traditional
treatments that already we know pretty
work pretty well but we can do it a
little better
we can create emotionally evocative
environments for example to help
patients with PTSD confront and process
difficult emotional memories in a safe
place and this is the core of prolonged
exposure an evidence-based approach and
clinician now has to learn how to
operate a control panel
to create the world in real-time around
the users experience to customize it
here's what that looks like everything
in this world is controlled in real time
by the clinician time of day the sound
effects explosions
number of people in the environment by
going through it there it's not going
through my head at night when I'm trying
to sleep and with my wife when time so I
don't want it to come up and we start
thinking about it traumatic things are
not normal and this is reliving the
worst moments of his life has helped him
to move on with his life
this is Dan Harris in Atlanta so last
piece how far are we gonna go with this
well what about a I driven therapist I'm
Ellie thanks for coming in today I was
created to talk to people in a safe and
secure environment I'm not a therapist
but I'm here to learn about people and
would love to learn about you I'll ask a
few questions to get us started and
please feel free to tell me anything
your answers are totally confidential
are you okay with this and this
definitely will be probably the most
contentious issue in clinical psychology
moving forward as AI gets better
where can we fill in gaps and where do
we start replacing real people you know
we can't tend to think factory workers
long distance truck drivers okay
Automation or not therapist well who
knows where that's gonna go I think we
have to tread very carefully and I'm
gonna stop there just a few hot topics
that I'll just list off here but thank
you for your time
[Applause]
hi everyone my name is Tom Siebel I'm a
researcher at Microsoft Research I
usually spend unexplainable amounts of
time trying to come up with a title for
my presentations and this time it was no
different and I was stuck with this idea
of a rooftop as a counter to a desktop
and the reason behind this is that from
where I come from the rooftop is thought
as a place where you hang out you move
away from your regular environment you
go there to relax to talk to other
people maybe have a cup of tea and well
this is an aerial view of taka which is
the city that I hail from it also
connects me to a son who is also from
there so I thought that this would be a
nice kind of metaphor to use but what I
wanted to point to it as part of my talk
is that we are no longer constrained to
being in one place to get our things
done and that also means that our
workers are also not considering to one
place or one notion in terms of getting
there achieving what they want to do so
I use this graphic in terms of thinking
about the workforce of the future on the
horizontal axis we have on one end the
human who brings their individual skills
and expertise to get things done on the
other end we have AI or automation that
at this point can help people do some of
those routine tasks so that people are
freed up to do the things that they're
good at and they have unique skills and
expertise on the vertical axis we have
the range of people who are doing that
task on the top we have the human again
individuals who can do smaller scale
tasks ranging to groups of people who
come together to get them something that
is big and substantial so in this sense
the workforce of the future is also
about the workplace of the future where
are these type of things getting done
and again I would like to make the point
is that doing work is no longer
constrained to being at a desktop or
being at a desk inside an office and if
you want proof of that think about the
amount of work that you can get done on
a laptop when you're away from your
office away from your natural
environment I mean even further proof
open up your smartphone and see how many
emails you have checked or triaged and
how many conversations you have had that
are maybe related to work part of the
reason why we think this way and why
this fits into the workplace of the
future is that that device ecosystem
that we have is become increasingly
mobile and this fits nicely into kind of
the fragment and attention concern that
we have is people have limited attention
because they are trying to do multiple
things at the same time if you go back
to this morning's keynotes and Gloria
Marc brought that up in many ways is
that we are having difficulties in
having focused attention so when we are
on a mobile device and we are going
across from we're always on the go
getting things done in a focused manner
becomes much more difficult and so those
are some of the challenges that we are
trying to address is that we have this
mobile workforce who are getting things
done when they're on the desktop but
they also have this opportunity to get
things done when they're mobile so this
is where the concept of micro
productivity is super relevant because
that exactly allows us to do those kinds
of things so if you had missed this
morning session on micro productivity
it's about getting things done in short
bursts of time which are contributing
towards a larger goal the reason why
micro productivity is relevant for this
conversation is because our attention is
fragmented or mobile devices actually
can do much more than it was able to do
before so we are able to not only do
communication but we're actually able to
carry out real tasks there are also many
micro moments throughout the day as the
presentation started maybe there is a
gap between the change of speakers maybe
some of you quickly checked your email
to say if there is something that
needed your attention when you're
transitioning from one place to another
you check your email you may be cross up
a couple of things from your to-do list
so we have these micro moments where we
can actually fit in a lot of things
there's also evidence that micro tasks
are more resilient to interruptions
because there are these small things
that you can actually finish before you
have to respond to an external
interruption so we are already doing a
lot of tasks that kind of are micro
tasks and these are mostly communication
kind of tests these are email desert
instant messaging to do's maybe some
kind of web browsers what we typically
don't think of is doing complex tasks in
terms of micro tasks and they're I mean
who wants to do coding or writing a
document on their phone or when they're
on the go and part of the reason is
because complex tasks are not only
suited for micro moments they're also
not necessarily suited for mobile
devices I mean think about trying to
read a document on your mobile phone or
trying to do back triage on your phone
it's not really easy so that's why we
have been trying to go with in our
research over the past few years and I'm
going to quickly go over a few projects
that show how we have started to think
about adapting the productivity test
that we have into these like smaller
micro tests that can fit into these
micro moments with the goal of
leveraging the mobile the time that we
have scattered towards the day and
getting something substantial done out
of it so I'm going to start off with
editing on the go so we typically don't
think of writing as something that we do
in small chunks of time though there are
parts of writing that we could actually
fit into these smaller micro moments so
we developed this tool called play write
which essentially is part of a framework
that extracts micro tests out of your
word document as an initial
implementation so we went with some
simple tasks like correcting spelling
correcting grammar shortening text and
we wanted to see that how people
interacted with these tasks when they
were on the go
the way does the test were designed is
that they're context-free so you didn't
need a ton of surrounding text to be
able to do the tests on the go and so
this is kind of like how it works you
work in a Word document it the the
framework or the word plugin extracts
the test and loads it up to a server
your mobile app pulls those tests down
you do the tasks and the outputs are
then fed back to the server and then
later integrated into the document so
again these are it looks like a very
game-like interface and that was one of
the motivations is that we wanted this
to feel not super engaging but something
that you can quickly go through get
things done move forward without feeling
that you're really eating into your
mobile time or your free time so the
once we did writing and it's by no means
finished we are still thinking about how
how we can move forward with this
research we started to think about okay
so let's look at even more complex tasks
what about programming because no one
wants to do programming on their phone
and last year as a part of a summer
intern project we talked to a bunch of
developers and we did a survey and we
asked them is that what do you use your
mobile phone for in test regard related
to programming so it turns out that
people are mostly using their mobile
phone when they're away from their
programming tasks for resource gathering
things that they wanted to do is they
wanted to do some kind of bug triage
something that's more related to
programming and part of the reason is
not because they want to keep on working
all day but it's actually it's almost a
contrast so they felt that they were
tethered to their desktop and they were
not able to leave because they couldn't
carry on their tasks in an opportunistic
fashion when they were away from the
desktop or away from their office so
that was kind of the motivation to see
that ok so what kind of tasks can we
offer on the mobile device that are
reasonably context-free that people can
do in short bursts and then the result
kind they can use them back later when
they come back to their programming
environment the other goal that we had
for this work was trying to see that
whether or not this helped people keep
the context alive
so if you're interacting with the mobile
interacting with a micro test on a
mobile device even though if it's a few
seconds of interaction it might help you
quickly resume your test when you get
back to your real programming
environment this one was a bit more
pushing the boundary of what what are
the things that we can do and this was
partly motivated by the fact that when
we are commuting we have this free time
essentially where we are driving we have
lots of thoughts and there's really no
good way of collecting these thoughts so
we wanted to see that okay so there is
some free time if I might say so and
they're ours or past research has shown
that there are there are moments during
driving where you have some cognitive
resources available to be able to do
other stuff now we are already doing
stuff in the car we are interacting with
in in vehicle systems we're talking to
people in the car but we're doing it in
a fashion that typically does not inter
interfere with your driving I mean at
least for the more I would say safer
drivers so we wanted to see and this was
a study in a driving simulator what
happens if we take a Productivity
related tasks such as editing a document
or creating a PowerPoint slide and try
to produce something via speech so the
idea was that there is an intelligent
assistant in the car that will converse
with the driver taking into account the
road conditions taking into account the
drivers mental state and as these
questions to the driver which would have
very short answers and in the process
these answers would be collected and
then compiled as a document later that
the driver can access so it turns out
that the design of these questions is
super important our system had two goals
one is that it asked certain very
specific questions about okay this is a
PowerPoint deck what is the title what
is it going to have any images are there
going to be bullet points so it's almost
like yes-or-no questions and if people
don't create slides that way it can be
incredibly disturbing so the other
option that we had tested is that we had
this assistant just lead people through
with okay
what next so again this suggests that if
we want to develop interfaces for the
car and we had done this research with a
model with an eye towards the future of
self-driving cars is that what kind of
things can we do in the car which is
still a limited attention environment
and so there are definitely some things
that we need to think about so yeah the
second last one is that the other other
thing is that when you how do you
disengage and re-engage at work so when
you leave work at the end of the day
people typically carry work with them at
home in their hands thinking about work
and so we wanted to see that can we use
the time when they're moving out of
their office can we use that time for
people to actually start redesignating
from work and help them reengage when
they come back later the next day and so
this was done via two simple questions
at the end of the day we asked them
about to reflect on what they had done
during the day and what they wanted to
accomplish the next day and the next day
when they would come back we would
reflect back that information that
people would that would help people
actually save time that they would
otherwise have used to to catch up an
information or catch up on the tests
they wanted to do for that day it turned
out to be surprisingly successful people
tended to be more productive in the
first hour when they came out and they
felt also less stressful when they had
had done that disengagement exercise at
the end of the day the last topic is
about ok so you have all these complex
tasks how do you create these workflows
or these micro tasks out of it
we wanted to just look at writing as our
starting example and so we did some
research looking at the comments that
people leave and documents which are
typically pretty abstract pretty pretty
high level and we wanted to see if we
could breakdown them in a manner that we
could identify micro tasks that the user
themselves could do or other people
could do or things that could be
automated that eventually would help
save effort and help the user focus on
things that were super that were that
they had the unique capability to
address
so this is kind of like our first step
towards creating these mobile workflows
and so we hope that we could start using
these kinds of vocabularies to help
people at least as a beginning to start
thinking about how we can help people
create micro tasks on-the-go and some
open questions that I had and so I'm
sure that these will come back during
the panel discussion is that how can we
easily identify what parts of a task can
be done when we are away from a desktop
so there are certain things that we do
need to have focused time for and we're
we're not suggesting that everything
needs to be done in micro moments what
is the quality of work I think that's
that's a fair question to ask is that if
I'm doing things on a mobile device is
how good is it and I mean the question
that is probably I mean on everyone's
mind how can we protect our time away
from work and on that note I'm going to
hand over to Phil well thank you very
much my name is Phil Pizzo I'm a little
different than many of you I'm a
physician scientist by background and
training and I want to talk with you
about a different aspect of the
workforce than we've talked about today
and that is the dramatic changes that
are taking place as a consequence of
lifespan and longevity you may not
recognize this but in a century we've
gained more than 30 years of life
expectancy in fact today and every day
until 2030 10,000 people are going to
across the age of 65 that's going to
mean that we'll have 20% of the
population in the u.s. who will be older
than 65 by that time but in fact in
Japan it's already 26% today and in many
parts of Western Europe and Asia it's
going to approximate 40 percent so this
is a significant shift in terms of how
we think about the social narrative that
begins with education work and
retirement and how we think societally
about how the impact of an aging
population is going to be on all of the
events that take place during the life
so when you think about this on an
individual level I think most of us as
we think about our lives would like to
have ourselves functioning fully until
the day we're biologically not able to
do so and then fall off the curve and
while there are some particularly in
Silicon Valley who have the illusion
that they'd like to like to live forever
my view is that we ought to be looking
at ways of aligning our lifespan in our
health span so they're mostly concordant
with each other but that's not what many
people get what most people wind up
having is a gradual decline loss of
function which by the way begins when we
cross the age of 30 but it accelerates
overtime and I think the question is can
we do something to attenuate that when
we look at this from a societal
perspective the Hartford Foundation has
actually looked at how they might grade
nations in terms of aging societies and
they've looked at a number of factors
that are important one of them is
well-being what's the degree of
disability the second is what's the
degree of equity how much disparity is
there in socioeconomic status the third
is cohesiveness what's the degree of
intergenerational interaction that's
taking place the fourth is productivity
are people continuing to be productive
and the fifth is security
how safe an environment is a country
bringing forward the u.s. actually does
pretty well on this scale largely
because of productivity which is
different from other parts of the world
where a mandatory retirement still
follows the benchmark that was first
guided by Bismarck in the 1880s when 65
was put forward as the age of retirement
and of course that was codified in this
country when Social Security came about
in 1935 but when you think about it if
you're in your 50s or 60s and you have
20 to 30 years ahead of you is it really
sensible to think about retiring when
there may be important ways of being
productive you know going forward so
this is I think a very important issue
for
and when you look at what people are
choosing to do now nearly 40% of
individuals who've crossed the age of 65
are seeking to continue to work and the
Transamerica study that was done last
year demonstrated that over 80% of
employers recognized that their
workforce might in fact like to continue
in some capacity going forward if you
look at people who have started new
business who have an entrepreneurial
activity outside of tech the average age
is about 47 and when you look at the
impact of an ageing workforce and some
companies such as BMW they've actually
demonstrated that you can increase
productivity and reduce loss of
personnel so it's important for us to
kind of think about what this means is
we go forward and with that context I
began wondering about what's the role of
higher education in helping people make
this kind of a transition here - there's
an old narrative higher education has
been doing the same thing for a
millennia which is important and it's
impacted all of us it's about educating
young people but as we think about our
transitions is there an opportunity to
think further about that going forward
we know from a lot of epidemiological
data studies done by Raj Chetty in the
last couple of years and Angus Deaton at
Princeton that education high school
education and above is one of the single
most important factors that contribute
to positive longevity but there are at
least three other factors that make a
major difference that we can do
something about and none of them will
surprise you but when you put them
together they might make a difference
one of them is the important of having a
sense of purpose when you wake up every
day you think about what you're going to
do and if it's meaningful to you that's
a really important thing we know from a
study that was just reported a month ago
from the University of Michigan based on
the retirement survey that in people
over 50 who've lost a sense of purpose
there is a highly significant difference
in all cause morbidity and mortality and
purpose here particularly for people in
midlife often has a more altruistic
generative component about people who
want to do something that's good not
necessarily in the same tradition that
they might have in the past the second
factor is connectedness or social
engagement it's interesting that two
studies were just published in the last
several months that demonstrate that in
the US and in fact in the UK in other
countries there is a prevalence of
loneliness of anywhere from 10 to 20 to
30 percent this is becoming a social
phenomenon that is really important and
we know that when people leave their
workforce that they often lose their
kind of their connectedness that is
really important to them and from
studies that we're done at the
University of Utah we know once again
from a large meta-analysis that when
people lose social connectedness there
is a significant increase in all cause
morbidity and mortality and not
surprisingly on the wellness side
looking at it from a physical emotional
and spiritual perspective when one to
maintains a sense of wellness it has a
huge impact on how well people do versus
not so with those in mind those three
variables that are interactive with each
other we started a program at Stanford
which we're using as a starting point in
exemplar which we think will have
relevance to other higher education
programs nationally and globally going
forward this is called the Stanford
distinguished careers Institute it's
built on these three intersecting
variables of renewing purpose building
community and recalibrating wellness the
program takes people who are in midlife
in our case it's anywhere from 40s to
70s we take a limited number of
individuals because we're interested in
sustaining community so we're admitting
30 people a year they can bring with
them or nominate a life partner or
spouse and they spend a year at Stanford
as a nun matriculated graduate student
now we're interested in those
individuals as part of a longitudinal
study whether we can compress their
morbidity that is shift to the right the
onset of chronic declines and make the
duration shorter but we're also
interested in whether
we can change institutions as well so
our fellows when they come to Stanford
come with a prior background they've had
very distinguished careers but they're
interested in shifting to something else
they just don't know how to get there
and so we asked them to choose a new
purpose pathway we align them with a
faculty adviser and then importantly
they take classes side by side with
undergraduate and graduate students same
classes they do the work and it creates
an incredible interactive environment
what we've seen in the last several
years since this program has been alive
is that it's literally changing the way
our students are looking at aging as
well they want to be partnered with
these individuals in midlife not just
because they want to talk about courses
but because they want to talk about life
and faculty love having them in the
class because they actually do the work
and pay attention during the classes as
well we work with our fellows to help
conquer ties their way of thinking about
purpose by having them collaborated with
our design school and developed a course
called designing your life which is a
year-long course that allows people to
work individually and in small groups
and then we complement that with memoir
writing and guided on a biography so
that as fellows go through the program
they're really thinking about what
they're going to be doing in the future
we build community by bringing people
together which is one of the most
powerful things that we have observed
people who have not met each other are
literally becoming new and indeed
lifelong friends and then we work with a
Wellness Group on recalibrating wellness
from our perspective what we're seeking
to do with this is to determine again
whether individually and collectively we
can compress more deep morbidity and
improve the quality of life we're not so
much interested in exactly what the
person does except we know that many of
them are seeking to go back to the
workplace in different ways as mentors
as teachers as advisors or for those who
are younger to start whole new jobs and
careers again now we're taking this one
step further because we're seeking to
collaborate
or set up a collaborative with other
colleges and universities around the
country in fact there have been a number
that have already started programs we're
not franchising this model but Notre
Dame University of Texas at Austin
University of Michigan have already
started programs there will be one at
Oxford next year and there are many
other large and small colleges and
universities that are interested in the
idea and what we're interested in is
ultimately developing a large population
science collaborative so that we can
test not only impact on individuals but
also societally from one thinks about it
given this big shift in the demography
that I've already addressed with you and
the unfortunate potential that unless
people are doing better they may consume
more resources a really important
question is can we reduce the need for
medical and social services if not only
individuals but communities are doing
better so what I'm describing to you
today is feature that we haven't yet
spoken about I don't think very much
during this conference and that is that
we're in the midst of this huge
demographic shift it's gonna alter the
way we think about work and workforce it
will shape the way we think about
retirement and productivity in the
future and we believe that higher
education serves as an important bridge
from transition from one career to a new
one for the future so thank you very
much for listening how many of you are
scared of public speaking resumes we
have a brief audience here well nobody's
scared well there's one in the honey in
stage so I'm gonna demo tool that can
give you feedback on your public
speaking skills I'm not gonna be able to
bring one year in and give a live demo
but I was able to get Eric Horvitz
during lunch to try this out it was
unscripted so I just was nice enough to
try this in a second notice so let's see
what kind of feedback he's received
so that's to interface I can you know
immediately can tell the purple line
correspond to smile so we did not smile
much the yellow line correspond to body
language so it's clearly something
happened here we can watch the video I'm
just amazed how little progress we've
made on what I I'm not going for the
interview but Li know something happened
interesting here so let's see and see
what why did that go up so I can go
there and take a look so what did you
tip you laid it with ease in context and
finally how do we learn from one task or
problem so you use gestures in a
meaningful way which is great so you can
also take a look at his volley
modulation and easy to quit job
modulating his volume we can also take a
look at what he said so it looks like he
said their filler words so multiple
times this is a word cloud of some of
the things he said and this is like it
automatically generated feedback and if
Eric is comfortable he can click on this
and that creates a private link that you
can share with people in your social
network or via email to people that you
trust and people can give them feedback
so let's take a look so let's say why
not smile a bit let me post it here I'm
just amazed how little progress ends
knowledge and in manipulated with ease
in context and finally how do we learn
so let me give a feedback on movement
nice job hand gestures and then I can
post it I can also comment let's give
them all maximum for participating one
problem and I can click here submit and
this is gonna appear and is in this
video here very shortly so this is a
recorded one this is what it looks like
when you get a bunch of videos from
people that you trust here this is where
the comments appeared
the red correspond to constructive or
positive comment this is more of like as
something to work on so immediately this
is a symbiosis of human feedback
combined with a I driven feedback so we
can go back and you know some of that
appear already why not smile a bit more
and all that so all right so this is a
tool that we built now and if you want
to mess with it you can go to rocks big
calm and do this on your own but
interestingly you can say this tool is
cute but does it really help improve
soft skills and if it does how does it
help so with my time today I will try to
answer these two questions so to study
this we ran an experiment or you hired
30 online workers Mechanical Turk ORS
and we give them a task where they would
upload videos of different job related
prompts every other day using the rock
speak platform and as you can tell the
first prompt and the last one are the
same so we can measure how well they
changed in the ten day period and also
we can look at take a look at the
trajectory of how they are improving so
in addition to getting AI driven
feedback we built a UI where they can go
in and it's like a Facebook feed where
they can select up to three people they
can give feedback to more people as well
and give them written feedback and we
combined them together and then we took
the video and showed it to experts from
Toastmasters in the random order to get
the performance and the control
condition here was individual to writing
comments to each other there was no AI
involved and the treatment was AI human
symbiosis so given the five prompt the
five videos you can tell in the
beginning treatment is doing slightly
better from three they catch up prom for
the both go down but treatment is doing
better and in prom five treatment are
significantly better than control and we
ran six independent instances of the
same experiment we're able to replicate
the results so going back to the first
slide yes it does help if you use a
metric called performance that's
standardized repeatable with that
metric we can tell something is changing
they're improving now the second
question which is a bit more difficult
to answer like why does it help right
that's when we made an observation that
imagine each person being a node and the
fact that they're writing feedback to
each other becomes an edge then the
entire interaction becomes a dynamic
network and when we frame it that way we
can use existing algorithm from Grau
signal processing or network science to
be able to model that interaction so
here you can tell that given that each
prom the connections are changing so how
do I study this how do I know that you
know that human element is doing
something because that's the hunch we
don't think the AI itself is doing
something the fact that people are
interacting with each other they're
showing empathy towards each other it's
something doing something through the
study that we set up a hypothesis we're
in a one condition we're gonna predict
their final performance which is a final
performing way looking at the past
history right so the linear regressor in
the other condition we're going to look
at the past performance as well as who
they interact with and their performance
as well
if the peer performance is doing
something hopefully in the second
condition we're going to do a better job
in predicting the final performance so
what do we find here we have this two
condition and one condition we have the
network another condition is network
agnostic and this is the error so lower
the number the better so in Group one
the 30 online workers we can do a better
job printing the final performance when
you take the network into the
consideration we repeated the experiment
again with six 30 more people and then
we're able to replicate this and we did
this four other times and we're able to
replicate the results now one problem
with the dynamic network is for given
prompt I can have three people give me
feedback but for the second problem that
can change new people can give me
feedback this really is difficult to
study how the peer interaction is
evolving through time because there's a
lot of noise so how do you fix this so
we ran the same experiment again but
this time with a static network see
imagine I am
the middle person I have three fixed
peers of friend and we're gonna give
feedback to each other and that's gonna
stay constant throughout the entire
experiment so when you instantiate that
this is what the network looks like and
then of course the condition remained
the same three fixed pair for every one
five problems in ten days and it allows
us to be able to track how the skills
are propagating across the network so
what do you find so we find that in both
static and dynamic network people do
improve their speaking skills in both
condition which is good one other
question is what attributes the
performance improvement and that's the
probably the most important information
I can give you today which is about the
quality of the peers so given the
network if the peer that I interact with
if they're better than me my performance
in that prompt will be better versus if
I'm stuck with people who are worse than
me my performance goes down so that's a
robust if I were able to see also in
terms of feedback if the feedback
contains words like excellent way to go
a great job not very helpful when it's
constructive like this is where I gave
you a lower rating this is how we can
fix it so that kind of feedback was very
indicative on improvement so that was
the qualitative metric we also had
people fill out a survey so we can run a
qualitative analysis as well so what we
found is people liked the fact that as
I'm giving you feedback they can come
back and take a look at my video to see
how I've done it so that kind of
connection was very helpful empathy was
a big part be able to show you know I
understand you're going through a tough
time I understand so those kind of
sentences those kind of support were
very valuable
some people make slow progress but it's
important that that's being acknowledged
so that was a very important aspect of
the improvement so if I give you a
performance like a speaking performance
and if there are three judges it's very
likely they're gonna have disagreement
with each other because that's what soft
skills are for it's very diverse and
that's why it's very difficult for AI to
be able to provide a metric but that's
exactly what the participants liked
about it because there's a huge
diversity in the type of feedback
they're receiving and they're able to
take a look and make a decision for
themselves and of course a sense of
community safety is always enjoyable so
within the two minutes that I've left
I'm going to show you two example of
zoom into a network and give you an
example of how people are interacting
and exchanging ideas here there are two
individuals ID 1899 they're both are
online workers the prompt was telling me
about yourself you can tell this person
hi I'm Julius and I'm a former tech
computer that's making the transition
into web development here's a few
highlights so that was the video and
then this peer wrote a comment like this
it's a bit unusual to stand in front of
your computer but if you can find a way
to do so comfortably I believe it would
help you with their movement and
gestures and if you take a look at a
video that's exactly what we did I have
this kind of gold logo back like you
know there's an example from it to go
follow so you can tell and the next
problem he tries that I would say my
biggest weakness is that a perfectionist
at times I'm very passionate about my
work and when he goes to prom for by the
end of Eid day so you can see is
significantly better so I was in a
situation where I had to meet a
challenge with my leadership skills I
was in my coding boot camp and we were
close to the end of it towards the end
and then a different peer came in and
acknowledged that progress and talked
about you're doing it great with the
appropriate gestures really does goes
along with your speech and helps bring
more enthusiasm and connectivity through
audience so that's one example let me
give you one other example so at zoom in
somewhere else
so here ID seven the prompt was telling
me about your greatest achievement and
this is just a regular online worker
with high school education as I said
previously I'm a stay at home mom
basically anything I talk about involves
my kids I don't
a lot outside of being a mom so from
that one of the peers talked about the
sentence drops down in tone at the end
of the sentence where you describe
yourself as a stay-at-home mom almost
like you're not impressed with yourself
you have pride in what you do and it
comes through later on the video but
started off good too
this is what you do you do it well
projected in your tone to convince us so
you can tell on the next prompt conflict
and leadership is played what being a
mom of four girls is all about I don't
know that there are many other houses a
habit was much conflict apart and then
person was able to come and acknowledge
that you came out so confident in the
beginning and felt that throughout the
video this is probably your strongest
video yet from what I've seen so in the
future we'll see a lot of this AI driven
technology being deployed but I think
it's really important to retain the core
skills that makes us more human so on
that note I will pass the torch to John
climber thanks alright thanks very much
as you can see we're running a
randomized experiments the speakers who
came before the demo that Sean showed
versus mine but I'm afraid the results
might not be pretty so one thing that's
been that's been the case in throughout
the talks I think has been the issue of
in the workforce of of the future that
the issue of composition right the ways
in which skip for example talked about
bringing new new new kinds of people
into the workforce people facing mental
health challenges returning veterans
this sustaining participation in the in
the workforce right the changing nature
of one's experience and it's over over
the life course as as what Phil was
talking about and of course the changing
nature of the work itself right things
like micro tasks the importance of soft
skills and computational interventions
that might might help with that and if
you think about it one of the things
that is latent in the background when we
think about composition you
is that there's a constant backdrop of
screening decisions in evaluation that
takes place right things like hiring
right things like school admissions for
example all of these which are acting is
gating functions right things like
promotion things like retention right
all of these are cases where someone
intervenes makes an evaluation of a job
applicant to college applicants a
co-worker up for promotion and a theme
that we've been seeing increasingly in
these domains is the following question
if humans are making these decisions and
humans are error-prone humans are
subject to biases could we potentially
improve things if we find the right way
to bring algorithms and AI into the
picture as part of these screening
decisions because after all many of
these follow a template that's
recognizable from the standard pipeline
of machine learning right we have an
individual someone very complex with
complex life experiences that we can't
possibly hope to fully represent we
create a set of features we pass them to
a decision maker who could be human or
algorithmic and we make some prediction
about future performance that might help
guide an end-to-end decision now the
challenge of course is that the fact
that we're trying to introduce something
that may be elder in their computational
this does not mean will necessarily make
things better we could equally well make
things worse and so the question is how
do we think about in in the case of what
I'll focus on here the the risk of bias
in particular right how does bias come
into Elric decisions but in fact
understand that we should ask how does
bias come into into into human decisions
now so with that in mind in the next few
minutes I want to talk about three main
points here first let's think about
human bias and human decisions and how
we can under how we can understand it
secondly if we bring all the rules into
the picture how can we regulate what's
going on how can we understand where
bias might be creeping in there and
finally to the extent that we can detect
by us an element of decision where is it
coming from what's contributing to it
okay so it helps to start with a few
definitions not mathematical ones but
actually legal definitions if we look at
the law on discrimination right so we're
you know we're engaging in an employment
decision an admissions decision we'd
like to ask is there bias taking place
that's actually leading to outright
discrimination that might be legally
challengeable then there are two broad
categories that's the body of law and
discrimination in the u.s. at least
recognizes the first is what's called
disparate treatment and that's when
there's actually an intent to
deliberately favor certain applicants on
protected categories such as race gender
national origin religion or age the
second is this broader class more
complex called disparate impact which
says regardless of your intent
if the screening decision you're making
has a disproportionate adverse effect on
some protected groups such as the ones
in the first bullet then the burden of
proof shifts to the decision-maker to
establish what's called business
necessity right so the canonical example
would be there may be a profession in
which you have to somehow do things that
involve reaching up very high and so
requiring some sort of minimum height
may simply be physically necessary on
their hand if I were hiring software
developers and I put in a height
requirement
it would be rather difficult to
establish business necessity for that
and so certain decisions that you're
making which have an adverse impact it
can matter whether you can justify them
on the grounds of business necessity
okay now an important thing for
understanding all of discrimination law
is that it's predicated on something
latent that's often not made explicit
but it has been there from the beginning
which is essentially a principle from
the behavioral sciences that it's very
hard to tell if a human decision-maker
has engaged in disparate treatment or
disparate impact why is this well well
when we think about difficulty in
detecting discrimination are thought to
merely go to the problem of obfuscation
or lying right you ask someone are you
discriminating and they'll say no
because because they're lying but
there's a much more fundamental
challenge and really what makes it much
harder is that people may genuinely not
know why they're making the decisions
that they're making even if they are
trying to help you as much as possible
to give their best effort at explaining
why they did what they did they may
simply not have the reasons correct and
in some sense I think this as we start
thinking about the role of algorithm and
computation right so far I've just been
talking about human beings may be the
most useful thing to take away from this
framing that I'm trying to put on the
problem is that when we think about the
question of interpretability
right often when we think about the
introduction of algorithms we're
concerned but the algorithm will be this
complex black box it will be unintuitive
us we will not be able to understand its
decisions and what I'd like to argue is
that both humans and algorithms are not
interpretive all they both have profound
challenges with interpretability
different ones but profound ones and
that humans provide us with this
illusion of an explanation right a human
being is always happy to tell you why
they think they did something but that
again that may not actually correspond
to interpretability
one place that we can actually look for
some compelling examples of this is a
long line of people science work one of
the seminal pieces of research here is
from the 1970s by this Nisbet and Wilson
in a paper with the suggestive title
telling more than we can know and what
they did was they would create these
conditions that were almost identical
whether it be a single difference
between them right condition a condition
B and people would do different things
in condition a and condition B one group
in a one group in B and then you would
ask people why did you make the decision
which you know was different in the two
situations and they would give you
reasons but none of the reasons were the
one thing that we know was different
between right so a simple example I I
asked you to name a brand and some
product category I asked you to name a
brand of laundry detergent okay but
before that I give you a word
memorization task I tell you please
memorize the following words
in one group they're just random the
another group I asked you to memorize
where is like beach beach ocean moon and
then I asked you to name a brand of
laundry detergent and many more people
say tide right that's a well-known
effect that's priming I've tried you to
think of the word tie but now they did
something very clever they ask people
why did you pick this one and if you
look at the reasons it's because you
know my family uses tide when I was
growing up we use tide I remember it
from an ad lots of things but never
because you primed me with these words
even though we know statistically that
is the only thing that changed between
these two conditions right so because
someone's telling you why they did
something that may not be the reason and
that's a big challenge right so that's
what these experiments are many
experiments in this category right I
asked you to choose an article of
clothing but like a stage magician I
sort of forced the right-hand one on you
but then you say the reason that you
chose it was because of the color or the
style or something like this same kind
of concept okay so a key point that we
like to make and this isn't some joint
work that I've been pursuing with people
from a range of different areas with
yen's Ludwig of public policy researcher
sandal molina 'then a behavioral
economist and Cass Sunstein a legal
scholar the four of us have been
thinking about this question of
algorithmic discrimination and rather
than try to get to the bottom of the
question will algorithms create more or
less by us something else that we're
there were thing about we want to pick a
sort of our thought and Alysha which is
that in any event there are ways in
which well regulated algorithms may make
discrimination easier to detect right if
we think about the black box of human
decision-making there are certain things
we can do with algorithms that we simply
can't do with human decisions now when I
when I say algorithms making screen
decisions there's a sort of important
definitional point to make here which is
there are always two algorithms that
we're talking about right the whole
point of machine learning is it is an
algorithm that produces an algorithm to
classify right so it's the training
algorithm but the up where the training
algorithm is an algorithm it is a
classifier which takes inputs and
produces classifications and the the
classifier and the trainer are both in G
interesting objects to
think about but our point is if these
things are constructed using the
standard pipeline of machine learning
when I show at the beginning right we
have a way of producing features we have
a way of producing target labels we have
a training procedure that evaluates on
some out-of-sample basis then we can do
certain things right we can't read the
code and expect to understand the
algorithm right that's both cognitively
difficult for human beings
mathematical facts like undecidability
tell us we can't ever expect to do that
but we can do certain things we can for
example examine the objective function
that you put into the train procedure
right what is it that you were trying to
optimize and part of the point is that
designing an algorithm for doing screen
decisions requires that you have a
discussion in a specification of what
your objective function is something
that you do not need to do if you're a
human making a decision in in an ad hoc
way right if you think about the human
hiring committees that you have sat on
there's not generally a discussion of
the objective function except in
extremely acceptable qualitative terms
we can also for example reproduce what
people did we can say okay give us your
data we're going to in the style of say
you know a Netflix prize competition
type of scenario we're going to build
our own screening rule and see can we
achieve similar performance with less
less bias we can for example provide
counterfactuals to the classifier we can
say I'm going to take this input but now
I'm going to flip the value of this
feature I'm going to flip the gender on
this input what would the answer be
right something that again is
essentially impossible right we can ask
that question to humans it's very hard
to get a real answer about that even if
they're trying their best now all of
this says we can perform these kinds of
inspections um but there's a key
adjective at the very first line of the
slide well-regulated our algorithms
clearly if the algorithm is in the
background we're not able to see the
features with the objective function
we're not able to see the classifier
then we simply have a situation where an
actor with bad intent now has a powerful
tool and algorithm hid in the background
there's nothing about that scenario that
should give us cause for hope but if
there's some kind of a record-keeping
requirement right that you need to
actually disclose the training data the
feature
the objective function that you used
then we can imagine doing these these
sorts of things and the key point here
is this may sound like an onerous
record-keeping burden but in many
industries when there's will to engage
in these in this kind of regulation it
often comes with comparably substantial
record-keeping requirements think of the
financial services in the industry where
the record-keeping requirements on
markets that sometimes total trillions
of dollars and exchanges can be quite
substantial and with this the final
points is that we could hope to actually
then decompose sources of bias in ways
that we really can't hope to in the case
of human decision-making this is again
not to say whether the bias will be
greater or less only that certain
aspects of detectability become much
clearer right we can now look at the
choice of the label or the outcome
people using we can look at how people
chose to create features from the
individuals and finally we can look at
the training procedure that was used
including the possibility the train data
may have been non representative or for
example that the future activity that
they're predicting may not resemble the
past and which was trained and so for
all these reasons I think there were
these interesting contrasts between
human decision-making and algorithmic
decision-making that I think should
inform how we think about the issues of
bias and discrimination in these two
modes human and algorithmic and I think
all of these are going to be an
important part of the backdrop for how
we think about the composition of the
workforce both at the level of entry at
the level of continuity and
sustainability and promotion as we go
forward thanks very much so you have
time for questions
what a volley from Bass University this
is a question to John so I hear this
argument judges who you mean decision
maker bias to but there are many of them
and their bass in in in in numerous many
different ways and one a spirit who need
to orbit algorithms is that there will
be a very very small number of algorithm
making important decisions that means
that we are now codifying a bias instead
of having yes there's a bias but it's
randomized but now we might have a kind
of a dominant bias in in some system
yeah I think that's a great question
I mean I I think actually in a number of
domains when we introduce algorithms we
see this danger of monoculture we see
this for example to take a very
different analogy in computer security
there's there's this concern that if
we're all running you know the same
system then it becomes susceptible to
the same exploits and that and there's
an analog of that going on here and I
think we could actually look to some of
those analogies right the introduction
of deliberate artificial head or
cultural for example right that we may
actually want multiple different
modalities we may want explicit
randomization I think is one is one
point I I think also it's useful to
think about you know we think about ad
hoc human decision making and then we
move to algorithms there's an
interesting interpolation point in
between which is the growth of
bureaucracy over the course of the 20th
century because bureaucracy was in its
own non electronic way an attempt at
systematizing certain processes so that
everyone would do things the same way
and so I think we can also look to some
of the thinking and organizational
behavior around how do we keep your
opportunity coming monolithic to the
extent that that has been successful as
a partial answer as well
Sydney thanks everybody for a really
insightful panel I had a question on the
micro testing tasking is that correct um
you know I think I think it's a really
neat idea and the way you guys have done
it I guess I was just thinking a little
bit I done some work a few years ago in
multitasking and there's a there's a
huge switch cast when you switching
tasks it's also just to put it bluntly
exhausting and I wonder if you've
collected those data in addition to
efficiency so that's that's one part and
second you know I'm thinking there is an
advantage we study daydreaming and mind
wandering there's an advantage to just
having those moments in the car where
you let yourself just just drift away
and you know it correlates with trait
creativity and such what are your
thoughts and kind of the trade-off thank
you
so I'll tackle the mind wandering
question first so there is actually
evidence that mind wandering in the car
can have negative impact because it
causes people to you lose control over
their conscious thoughts and so there is
some effort and kind of like trying to
rein in those thoughts so that you don't
totally lose your focus on the road
coming back to micro tasking and
multitasking we have done some studies
around what are some of the benefits of
micro tasking versus multitasking and
the way that I differentiate this is
that multitasking is where you are
switching and switching could happen at
different levels so it could be within a
task I'm switching from maybe writing a
document to saving it that's a very very
low level task and then it could be at a
high level that I'm switching from
programming to checking my email the
reason why and we have found that in
studies where we look at micro tasks
performance versus just like having a
larger macro task the reason why micro
tests often perform better in certain
settings is because these are
self-contained a little units of things
and so you once you complete one you
move
to something else and because the
context is typically contained within
that task that means that you are able
to quickly ramp up to that now we have
used market has in different ways so we
have used to actually start or use a
bunch of micro tasks that are all on a
related content to start building up
some of the context so that it helps you
launch into something bigger but yeah
there are different ways that you can
think about not a test we have also
thought of my multi sorry micro tasks as
a way of breaking context and so if you
totally randomized that okay you're
going to do this type of micro tasks and
the next one is on a completely
different topic
it works in certain situations it was
awful in the car study that I hadn't
described that was the pilot part and we
totally abandoned that okay we have to
have some kind of rhyme or reason to why
the system is asking certain questions
it can be totally out of the blue I have
a question fulfil so you talked about
the senior people and you recruit senior
people you try to give them the college
education so that they can have second
under the career but I'm thinking thank
you is this reasonable because like for
senior people the cognitive capacity and
and also other skills they are different
and so well that of course second career
is good but what that add stress to them
yeah that's number one number two is the
like it's a culture also different like
in China for example people retire then
they help to raise their grandkids then
this is also some kind of like
activities and keep them busier yeah so
what do you think like that his choice
let me take your let me take your second
question first because I think it's an
important issue in its own right first
of all in China as you know retirement
is very young it's currently 55 for
women and 60 for men so this
is a big issue when you think about
lifespans that are going to go on for 20
30 40 years it is absolutely true that
if you look at the data in terms of how
come their number of studies that have
shown that grandparenting because it is
a sense of purpose has a positive
correlation without coming in its own
right what it doesn't do necessarily is
create community so it may not prolong
the well-being of the individual in the
same manner so this is a you know second
issue but there are different very
different social structures in different
parts of the world you know as you
certainly know to the point you began
with here's what we do know we do know
that and this speaks to the session that
you ran this morning processing speed
changes dramatically over time so my
processing speed is significantly
different than it was when I was in my
20s or 30s but at the same time over
time one gains a combination of
knowledge and wisdom so these are huge
correlates and I think that's one of the
reasons why these intergenerational
relationships that I described to you
are so profound and so meaningful I'll
finally say that our students our
fellows when they are in classes where
the demands are high do have a lot of
anxiety but they have found ways of
overcoming them and feeling very proud
at the end of that so my question is for
Phil as well just building upon that a
little bit so it was really fascinating
to hear about you know the sense of
purpose and connectedness that you
talked about in addition to talking
about second careers for people who have
already accomplished something in their
first careers has there been any work in
revamping higher education or even K to
12 education to help younger people
identify a sense of purpose or that
connectedness because there is a crisis
among
younger people when it comes to mental
health and you know suicides and so on
yeah so has there been any work yeah so
a couple of things first of all some of
the initial work on purpose was done by
Bill Damon
and he studied adolescents from the ages
of 13 to 21 and broke them down he
followed at 1200 young people and broke
them down into four categories about 25
percent have no sense of purpose about
25 percent have a significant sense of
purpose and then the others are kind of
in the middle you know sort of dabblers
adventurers obviously that has an impact
on how people do in life and then
they've repeated that study actually in
individuals over 50 and same number and
about a third of individuals over 50
fall into this category of purpose with
this caveat its purpose beyond the self
so purpose beyond the self means that
I'm not just interested in my financial
security or my job I'm interested in can
I change my community can I change the
world can I do something that's gonna
have a larger impact and that's one of
the things that correlates with this
positive outcome that I addressed before
I take the next question let me stir up
a bit of controversy how many of you who
attended the morning session on the
micro productivity because some of you
okay a lot of you so you may remember
the dark question the session ended with
Moshe Verde talked about Taylorism like
in the 19th century interest is will use
Taylorism where they would take a large
task and break into small chunks and
some of the downside could be contain
unpleasant or unethical tasks and break
into smaller chunks and have people do
them without their consent or maybe
there is only one way to do the best
result you never tried the other ways to
get to the optimal results so my
question to Chomsky is as you try
productivity what are the negative
implications and how do you really me to
get those yeah I thought that I had
dodged that question
and passed it on to my panelists during
that session so yeah of course you had
to bring it back I know I knew that this
was going to come back to me at some
point it's a valid question
as I said in in that session is that we
are not right now looking at the
positives but there's of course there's
going to be going to be negative people
are going to exploit this people are
gonna use this in different ways to kind
of like get there
I mean underlying things done but I
think that it also maybe boils down to
letting people know about what is the
bigger picture here and so if you do a
task what are you actually contributing
towards I think that's one the other one
is that let people explore their own
ways of doing things so it's not that
everything needs to be scripted in a
particular way that you need to do a
certain thing in this particular
workflow it could be in different ways
and what we are looking at is that let
people come up with their own breakdowns
of things we already do that in some
sense different people break down the
same tasks in different ways and they
would do it in different ways so we're
not necessarily saying that it needs to
be totally scripted but yes I think that
there's dark sites especially about how
you what do you do with this kind of
like encroaching practice of wanting to
do work all the time because if you give
people tools to do work they will
continue to do work and so how do you
create those boundaries and make sure
that people are able to disengage and
relax and the importance of breaks and
taking walks how do you and if you look
at the current research about
multitasking these things are becoming
more and more in the forefront a few
years ago it was all about being
productive how can you make people get
more done be more efficient but now the
conversations around well-being and
mental health all of these things are
coming through so we're not thinking in
just one dimension we have to be kind of
like much more broader good for you
hopefully really love the well all of
the talks but I love the discussion
around the distinguished careers
Institute I'm at that age
I'm not going to apply but I'm at that
age I just recently retired but I'm also
wondering I loved the intergenerational
aspect of it that you've alluded to and
I'd love more detail on that maybe later
but I was thinking that in the context
of is are there thoughts of broadening
what you're doing broadening the mission
and I'm thinking in general there are a
whole lot of college campuses where the
dormitories are mostly empty during the
summertime there are a lot of teens at
risk out there without any sense of
purpose and maybe or more without a
sufficient sense of purpose to stay away
from some of the temptations that might
lead them astray so is there any thought
to and then the intergenerational part
of that is I don't know how you would
bring that together but I would you know
is there any thought to extending what
you're doing to the to the benefit both
of people in my age and people maybe
younger than college students I mean
let's let's figure Stanford College
students are probably likely already on
a successful path but what about all the
teens that maybe could benefit from a
summer on a college campus yeah
absolutely
well I think this whole I'll be brief
about this because I think the whole
concept of intergenerational interaction
is really important for all of our
futures and there are many different
formulations that that can take place in
so I'll give you one example that's not
related to what we're doing but you know
many young people when they leave
college like to go to do Teach for
America or something like that it turns
out that that tends to be a very highly
stressful job throwing a young person in
a classroom in a very challenged
environment if you pair that person with
someone in middle age or above the
outcome is significantly better for all
parties so I think there are lots of
examples that we can can look at our our
college campus at Stanford literally
becomes a high school during the summer
and I think you're right there's lots of
ways of you know bringing these
communities together I'm actually
looking at not just faculty per se but
you know we wind up having tons of
emeritus faculty who become without a
anchor and yet they can also participate
very actively in some of these settings
so the point is well-taken
okay thank you for all these
presentations they're really
thought-provoking and I apologize I have
very labels and questions for you one of
them I guess is related to the micro
tasking as well as to the distinguished
careers program it seems like there is
this cliff in the number of working
hours pre and post retirement and I
wonder if there's any research probably
from the data that Tom C has about how
many hours should people be working an
age adjusted basis and I guess the other
question which is more to the
distinguished careers program it seems
like the goals of this program are a lot
similar to the goals of urban design
where you're trying to create connected
communities you're trying to create a
sense of purpose and I wonder you know
why should we as academics be solving a
problem which has some pretty good
solutions in urban design or
alternatively what can we learn from
that should I go first well thank you
for the idea of a new research project
and so maybe Phil and I can start
collaborating but yeah I think that
that's a great question I mean as I
mentioned in the in the session this
morning so Jamie and I had this idea
that well we want to reduce the workweek
from 40 hours to 30 hours without
actually reducing the work it's just
that we want to make one work so
efficient that you can actually end up
saving time that is a concept we don't
have any metrics about that yet we are
hoping that being just by abling people
to move away from the desktop maybe we
can actually make use of these unusable
moments so if you kind of like defrag
them together you get something that's
useful it would be really fun to look at
how it helps as people kind of like
progress to their career and we reach at
a point of retirement my my dad is a
medical doctor he retired a few years
ago and he was fine just painting and
did kind of like what
movies and then suddenly last year he
decided that he wanted to go back and
teach so I mean he wanted to have some
kind of purpose but maybe you how do you
ease people into that and ease them out
because now he's also again saying that
I don't want to do it anymore but I mean
I digress a little bit but I think that
there's also some opportunity of
thinking about okay so are there ways
that we could leverage the knowledge the
skills the expertise that this group of
people have and then make them feel that
they are contributing they are
participating stuff they're making
progress without having them to feel
that they're overwhelmed last question I
have a question for John about bias so
you talked about counterfactual analysis
by flipping future values so you assume
that the data set you have it has all
the features or all the feature values
so what if you had missing values and
missing features how would you attack
the bias problem thank you right yeah so
those are those are very good questions
that the counterfactual point there was
relatively narrowly scoped which is
simply that if I have an algorithm it's
capable of answering questions about
synthetic data in a way that people are
not not necessarily as equipped to do
but the broader question of missing
values or even worse missing features is
extremely important it comes up in a
number of ways one is often features are
missing for reasons of the upstream
process that produced the data so for
example I am trying to train something
to evaluate job applicants if I attempt
for example to train it on the people
I've already hired then I'm training it
on people who were actually subject to
the selection process that as humans we
had already applied so we have a
selective labels problem and we you know
in which there may be bias that even
effects which people have labels in
which people don't in the
training data there's also the issue of
features that we simply didn't think to
measure for example right so there there
could be attributes of people that are
significant for the decision tasks they
weren't recorded and I think this is
actually a sort of one technical
interpretation of the more qualitative
or subjective concern that people have
when they say algorithms can't provide
individualized evaluation of people
right so one often hears this fear that
the problem if we deploy an algorithm is
it won't be able to you know give you an
individualized assessment in the same
way a human could initially that's
puzzling because after all isn't the
algorithm taking you as input and
running but I think if you sort of dig
into you know how might we formalize
what's what's going on there it says
that you know we collect some features
about someone it could be a hundred it
could be a thousand it could be a very
wide feature set despite that in your
particular case there will probably be a
thousand in first feature or a 3,000
feature that has very low recall right
it's relevant to you but to very few
other people that to a human with their
domain knowledge they would be able to
link that with other things that they
know and have that effective decision
the algorithm is not equipped to do that
and I think that's a that's quite a
broad open problem where the standard
vocabulary of algorithms of machine
learning is not directly equipped to
handle that right how do we talk about
features that we did not think to
collect right this is not a feature
selection problem where we say I have a
thousand features which ten are the most
informative this thing I have a thousand
features what did I not even measure
that as someone with more domain
knowledge would have thought to measure
and and that again it's a very wide open
question that is in at the panel let's
thank we're speaker again thank you
[Applause]